die bahnhofstraße in mainz sollte die
neue visitenkarte der stadt sein
ein moderner boulevard geplant für satte
2,4 millionen euro wurde saniert und
renoviert natürlich durfte auf der
prachtstraße auch kein 08 15
straßenbelag liegen als
fastnachtshochburg entschied man sich
für ein konfetti pflaster aber vom
konfetti muster ist nach ein paar
monaten fast gar nichts mehr zu sehen
stattdessen ist das dreckig schmierig
schmuddelig irgendetwas ist hier
kolossal schiefgelaufen wieder boten
aussieht ist katastrophal
ich kann es nicht verstehen weil es ist
ja nicht so als wären jetzt hier ist
erste mal platten gelegt frisch verlegt
sah das beige graue pflaster noch
richtig strahlend aus doch solch ein
heller bodenbelag ist natürlich
empfindlich deshalb müssten die platten
eigentlich mit einer versiegelung
geschützt werden aber die stadt mainz
hat sich die imprägnierung der
oberfläche gespart die folge der track
bald nicht ab sondern zieht in den beton
rein
aber warum hat die stadt mainz das
konfetti pflaster nicht versiegelt die
überraschende antwort diese option
konnte aufgrund der hohen zusätzlichen
kosten nicht weiter verfolgt werden
aha die option hätte 30.000 euro
zusätzlich gekostet dass bei einem
solchen millionen projekt am ende
ausgerechnet beim imprägniert schutz
gespart wird versteht die mainz niemand
also ich jetzt bei mir zu hause anders
gemacht so dass es sauber bleibt ich
finde schade dass man steuergelder
eigentlich rausschmeißt weil wenn man
schon so viel ausgibt wäre es einfach
sinnvoll diese imprägnierung drauf zu
machen
im rathaus will man von einem
planungsfehler nichts wissen man räumt
lediglich kleinlaut ein
die stadt mainz ist mit dem
verschmutzungsgrad wie er sich aktuell
in der bahnhofstraße zeigt selbst sehr
unzufrieden dass eine der belebtesten
straßen der stadt einiges an dreck und
belastung ab können muss damit haben
zumindest die bürger gerechnet
das ist eine verschwendung weil einfach
nicht nach bzw
vorher gedacht wurde oder vorausgedacht
wurde weil man weiß wie es aussehen wird
in spätestens einem halben jahr unser
sieht ja jetzt auch aus es würde ein
ewiges ärgernis bleiben
ganz aktuell hat die stadt eine
spezialfirma zur reinigung durch die
bahnhofstraße geschickt sauber ist das
pflaster nicht aber ein bisschen heller
ist es vorläufig wieder geworden und
drüben auf der anderen straßenseite
sollen jetzt auch platten verlegt werden
diesmal sogar versiegelte die stadt
mainz ist also lan fähig wenigstens das